whatever it is that you want to do your
there's gonna be risk in your life and
risk is a necessary component of
progress you can make any pioneering
movements in the world of any kind
whether they be the geographical
physical exploration that I've just been
talking about whether it be you know a
more cerebral exploration of a
scientific field or I bet you could ask
that question of every speaker here and
I bet that every speaker here has taken
substantial risks whether it be
intellectual or otherwise to achieve
what they're you know what they've done
people think that entrepreneurs take
risk and they get rewarded because they
take risk in reality entrepreneurs do
everything they can to minimize risk
they're not interested in taking risk
they want free lunches and they go after
free lunches and so if you study on any
number of entrepreneurs from Ray Kroc -
you know herb shorts at Starbucks and -
even even Buffett and Munger and so on
what you'll find is that they've
repeatedly made bets which are low risk
bets which have high return
possibilities so they're not going high
risk high return they're going low risk
high return and even with Bill Gates for
example the total amount of capital that
ever went into Microsoft was less than
fifty thousand between the time it
started and today that's the total
amount of capital that went into the
company so Microsoft you cannot say was
a high-risk venture because there was no
capital deployed but it had high
uncertainty Bill Gates could have gone
bankrupt or Bill Gates could have ended
up the wealthiest person on the Forbes
400 and he ended up at the extreme end
of the bell curve and that's fine but he
did not take risk to get there he was
comfortable with uncertainty so
entrepreneurs are great at dealing with
uncertainty and also very good at
in amazing risk that's the classic great
entrepreneur my intention with this
video was to spread understanding not
fighting I want you to see that it's not
one point of view or the other you can
pull and learn from both especially the
one that you don't immediately resonate
with embrace the genius of the end